Alejandro mayorkas I'm Margaret Brennan I'm
moderator of Face the Nation and I'm cbs's
Chief Foreign Affairs correspondent I also happen
to be a member of the board of directors here at
the Council on Foreign Relations so I will be
presiding later over the discussion we'll have
but first secretary mayorkas has some remarks and
he will be joining us here at the
podium to deliver those Mr sector
well good morning everybody Margaret thank
you for the introduction and thank you for
the discussion we're going to have in just
a few minutes my thanks to the Council on
Foreign Relations for hosting us and
thanks to all of you for being here I
would like to recognize two individuals
if I may who have special meaning to our
department our second Secretary of
Homeland Security Michael chertoff
people and and former United States
congresswoman Jane Harmon [Applause]
reflecting on the state of our homeland
security in 2023 it seemed fitting to
pose a fundamental question to a generative
AI model in one sentence describe how the
homeland security threat environment
has evolved over the past 20 years
we are after all confronting a dramatically
changed environment compared to the one we
faced in March of 2003 one that could change even
more dramatically as AI grips our imaginations
and accelerates into our lives in Uncharted and
basically unmanaged fashion deeply fascinated
by ai's promise of new advances and discoveries
greatly concerned for its capacity for error and
its impact on our Humanity and keenly alert to its
potential for harm in the hands of an adversary I
waited only seconds for the AI model's answer the
homeland security threat environment has evolved
from a primarily focused counter-terrorism
posture to a complex and diverse landscape
of challenges that include cyber attacks domestic
extremism and the covid-19 pandemic among others
a straightforward answer to an important question
that addresses the Evolve threat landscape that
our Department of Homeland Security must now
confront its evolution is about to accelerate
only about six months ago engaging with an AI
chatbot was reserved for a few in Silicon Valley
and universities today about 100 million users
per month are asking an AI chatbot just about
anything from recipe recommendations
to requests for scientific analyzes
the exponential growth of internet technology and
the change it has driven has been extraordinary
as we reflect on the state of our homeland
security today that explosive growth compels
us to ask the question what will this growth mean
for our Safety and Security over the next 20 years
we stand at the outset of what President Biden has
aptly described as a decisive decade for our world
it is the same for our homeland security
revolutionizing technological innovations
growing political and economic instability
widening wealth inequality a rapidly changing
climate increasingly aggressive nation states
emerging infectious diseases and other forces
are transforming the global landscape challenging
and sometimes rendering moot a nation's borders
and bringing National and international threats
to any community's doorstep our department was
founded to protect us in the wake of the tragedy
and Devastation inflicted by the terrorist attacks
of 9 11 bringing together 22 agencies from across
the federal government charged with the mission of
securing our homeland back then our country was
focused on the threat of foreign terrorists who
sought to enter the United States and do his harm
over the next 10 years emerged the threat of the
Homegrown violent extremists the individual
already resident here who was radicalized to
Violence by a foreign terrorist ideology while
those threats certainly persist today loan
offenders and small cells of individuals
motivated by a wide range of Grievances
and violent extremist ideologies from white
supremacy to anti-Semitism to anti-government
Attitudes pose the most persistent and lethal
terrorism-related threat in the United States
the effects of climate change have intensified
Wildfire season is no longer confined to the
summer months but is now year round tornadoes and
named hurricanes in the United States are more
frequent and more destructive just a few weeks
ago in Mississippi I surveyed the devastation
wrought by a tornado that in 20 seconds in its
speeds up to 200 miles per hour ripped through
a small town destroying multiple communities
and taking the lives of more than 20 people
not for a century have we confronted the Calamity
of an infectious disease as we have over the past
three years covid-19 took more than one million
lives here in the United States impacted every
aspect of our daily life and forced on us a new
understanding of the threat pandemic diseases can
pose as they spread through Paths of international
trade and travel globally the impacts of disasters
coupled with the rise of authoritarianism
corruption conflict violence and persecution have
resulted in an historic displacement in migration
of people around the world and a consequent strain
on immigration systems ill-equipped to address it
according to the United Nations High Commissioner
for refugees at the end of 2021 89.3 million
people worldwide had fled their homes due to
conflict violence fear of persecution and human
rights violations this is the most since World War
II and more than double the number of people
who remained forcibly displaced a decade ago
criminal organizations have capitalized on this
surge the region growing ruthlessness of smuggling
organizations have changed how people migrate
drug trafficking organizations have grown in
sophistication and power creating new means of
manufacturing and selling death and destruction
from late 1990 1989 through 2001 I prosecuted
federal drug trafficking crimes from the
trafficking of cocaine to methamphetamine to Black
to our heroin and more nothing I saw then matches
the scourge of fentanyl that we have confronted
over the past five years forty six thousand eight
hundred two overdose deaths in 2018. fifty seven
thousand eight hundred thirty four in twenty
twenty and seventy one thousand two hundred thirty
eight in twenty Twenty One over that same time
those seeking to exploit the most vulnerable have
taken their depravity to an unimaginable level
the national Center for missing and exploited
children the nation's Clearinghouse for child
sex sexual abuse material received over 32 million
cyber tips in 2022 corresponding to more than 88
million images and videos of child sexual abuse a
roughly 75 percent increase in the last five years
88 million images and videos of child sexual abuse
as threats of the past have changed in
form complexity and magnitude so too
have new threats emerged this is perhaps
nowhere more acute than in cyberspace
some estimates that roughly 14.4 billion devices
are connected as part of part of the Internet of
Things everything from our home thermostats
and doorbells to our electric grid and fuel
pipelines this has brought significant advances
in capabilities and conveniences but it also has
dramatically increased the ways our interconnected
digital world can be exploited to do us harm
today malicious cyber actors are capable
of disrupting gasoline supplies and across
an entire region of our country preventing
hospitals from delivering critical care and
causing disruption in some of the
school systems around our country
nation states like the People's Republic of China
and Russia upend are rules-based international
order and threaten our security at home whether
through cyber tax abuse of our trade and Travel
Systems or through disinformation campaigns that
seek to undermine our Democratic institutions
our homeland security has converged
with our broader National Security
the profound evolution in the homeland security
threat environment changing at a pace faster
than ever before has required our Department of
Homeland Security to evolve along with it we have
built new institutions modernized our approach
and processes developed new capabilities and
are harnessing Innovation as we deliver critical
services that are more in demand than ever before
are overarching strategy is one of partnership
Homeland Security cannot be accomplished by
government alone it requires Collective action
to meet the threat of domestic violent extremism
we created the center for prevention programs and
Partnerships to share with local communities
the best practice models of identification
and intervention when an individual is
exhibiting signs of moving towards violence
through our grant programs we are helping
communities build threat prevention capabilities
where previously they did not exist responding
to the reality that major metropolitan areas are
no longer our adversaries only targets across the
federal government we are working with communities
impacted by unprecedented extreme weather
events to strengthen their long-term recovery
we have developed for the first time
department-wide Incident Management teams to lead
all of government responses to emergent challenges
from vaccinating millions of Americans against
covid-19 and resettling Afghan Nationals in
operation allies welcome to providing protection
for fleeing ukrainians in uniting for Ukraine we
are coordinating and sharing intelligence with our
partner Nations and executing whole of government
disruption and dismantlement campaigns to attack
cartels in collaboration with diaspora communities
here in the United States we are building lawful
Pathways so that migrants fleeing persecution
can access safe and orderly Avenues to obtain the
humanitarian relief that our laws provide we are
working collaboratively with our partners across
government at home and abroad and with industry
and Academia to manage and reduce risk to the
Cyber and physical infrastructure Americans
rely on every single day we are partnering
across the U.S government to protect the most
vulnerable from exploitation whether they are
migrants being trafficked and by unscrupulous
Smugglers or children who are being abused online
exploitation of the vulnerable yesterday
we released the third quadrennial Homeland
Security review our new vision for securing the
Homeland in it we address the five major missions
set forth in our two prior reviews countering
terrorism securing our borders administering
our immigration system securing cyberspace and
critical infrastructure and building resilience
and responding to disasters for the first time
however we added a six Homeland Security Mission
set the work of combating crimes of exploitation
including human trafficking child exploitation
and labor exploitation this pivotal Edition
reflects the overriding importance of supporting
victims and stopping the perpetrators of these
abhorrent and increasingly prevalent crimes
but what of the threats as they could materialize
tomorrow I want to highlight new initiatives in
two key areas that cut across all the Department's
missions the People's Republic of China poses an
especially grave threat to the Homeland one that
indeed does touch all of our Department's missions
Beijing has the capability and the intent to
undermine our interests at home and abroad and is
leveraging every instrument of its National Power
to do so from its increasingly aggressive presence
in the South China Sea to the overseas police
stations used to harass and intimidate dissenters
a PRC invasion of Taiwan would have
profound reverberations in the Homeland
putting our civilian critical infrastructure
at risk of a disruptive Cyber attack we must
ensure we are poised to guard against
this threat today and into the future
I have directed A 90-day department-wide Sprint
to assess how the threats posed by the PRC will
evolve and how we can be best positioned to guard
against future manifestations of this threat one
critical area we will assess for example involves
the defense of our critical infrastructure against
PRC or prc-sponsored attacks designed to
disrupt or degrade provision of national
critical functions so Discord and panic and
prevent mobilization of U.S military capabilities
another area of assessment will involve how
we can bolster our screening and vetting to
identify illicit travelers from the PRC who
exploit our lawful immigration and Travel
Systems to collect intelligence steal intellectual
property and harass dissidents while still we must
facilitate lawful travel informed by engagements
with subject matter experts and our stakeholders
we will take immediate action to drive down risk
lay the foundation for ongoing public-private
collaboration and work with Congress to ensure
we continue to invest in these vital capabilities
next and returning to where I began we must
address the many ways in which artificial
intelligence will drastically alter the threat
landscape and augment the Arsenal of tools we
possess to succeed in the face of these threats
our department will lead in the responsible use
of AI to secure the Homeland and to defending
against the malicious use of this transformational
technology as we do this we will ensure that our
use of AI is rigorously tested to avoid bias and
disparate impact and is clearly explainable to
the people we serve I recently asked our homeland
security advisory Council co-chair Jamie gorelick
is here to study the intersection of AI and
Homeland Security and deliver findings that will
help guide our use of it and defense against it
the rapid pace of technological change the pivotal
moment we are now in requires that we also act
today to that end I am directing the creation of
our departments First artificial intelligence task
force that will drive specific applications of AI
to advance our critical Homeland Security missions
the task force will for example integrate AI
into our efforts to enhance the Integrity of our
supply chains and the broader trade environment we
will seek to deploy AI to more ably screen cargo
identify the importation of goods produced with
forced labor and manage risk the task force will
also among other charges leverage AI to counter
the flow of fentanyl into the United States
we will explore using this technology to better
detect fentanyl shipments identify and interdict
the flow of precursor chemicals around the world
and target for disruption Keynotes in the criminal
Networks countering the multi-faceted threat posed
by the PRC learning from major cyber incidents and
harnessing the power of AI to advance our security
will draw on the entirety of the capabilities and
expertise the 260 000 Personnel of DHS bring to
bear every single day it will require continued
investment in our operational cohesion our
ability to work together in ways our Founders
never imagined we must never allow we must never
allow ourselves to be susceptible to failures of
imagination which as the 911 Commission concluded
nearly 20 years ago held us back from connecting
the dots and preparing for the destruction
that was being planned on that tragic day
we must instead look to the Future and imagine
the otherwise unimaginable to ensure that
whatever threats we Face our department our
country will be positioned to meet the moment
it is an especially challenging imperative to
fill at a time not only of Rapid change but also
of acute political divisiveness when issues
of Homeland Security that traditionally were
unifying no longer are so and when our adversaries
continue to exploit Innovations designed to bring
us closer together like social media to in fact
push us apart we must imagine a world where even
more potent and lethal synthetic opioids or
infectious diseases plague our communities
where an earthquake or catastrophic storm
intensifies already historic levels of
migration in our hemisphere we're criminals 3D
print weapons or modify consumer Technologies
like drones to evade law enforcement were cyber
criminals are emboldened to the point of holding
for ransom the critical Services of an entire
city at the Department of Homeland Security we
have the tools and talent to meet the moment
today we are taking the actions and making the
Investments to ensure we will continue to
adapt and meet the moment into the future
we are more fit for purpose than at any time in
our 20-year history this is a collective effort
we must all come together in this country
in the service of our homeland security
we must call upon our Collective imagination our
commitment to a better future and our fundamental
love of country that binds us together to
protect our homeland thank you [Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you and thank you Mr
secretary first of all you've had an
eventful week so thank you for uh
spending this morning I am actually
looking forward to the opportunity
to answer a question [Applause]
um and just a reminder the
meeting is on the record
um so Mr secretary I want to ask
you a number thank you all for uh
I want to get into the substance of a lot of the
things you've just laid out here and I do want
to get to the Border as well before we take
questions from those here today but first of
all you talked about trying to bring together the
country and that's kind of where I want to start
seems like the past few weeks have been fairly
horrific but mass shooting in Alabama 32 people
you have a 12 year old who has just gunned down
in Hartford Connecticut along with others you
have a six-year-old girl shot in North Carolina
along with her parents when her ball went into
the neighbor's yard we have shooting upon shooting
and it just feels like it's it's a constant toxic
headline about neighborhoods becoming
Killing Fields And I wonder how you
think about that in the context of Homeland
Security what's happening in our country
so um Margaret thank you for the
opportunity so I will say this you know
um a mass shooting is defined as one that
victimizes four or more individuals we have
had more mass shootings in this country
in 2023 than we've had days of the year
um our role in addressing targeted violence
uh whatever the motive is to fund communities
to equip and Empower them to
identify when an individual
is descending down a path to
violence and understand what to do
say so in my mind that speaks to the abandoned
backpack by a bench or in the airport it doesn't
speak to a family member a neighbor a friend a
teacher a faith leader who observes somebody who
is exhibiting signs of really having trouble and
expressing interest in a violent act and we as a
community have to get involved and have to engage
and understand how to communicate an analogous
call to action when it involves something
like that on the issue of violence writ large
it's a much broader question than than just our
department it's an issue of our gun culture the
prevalence and ease of accessing military style
weapons It's a combination of multiple factors
it's um it's a lot it's a lot and by the way
a lot frankly in my International engagements
in my International engagements there are
two questions that almost every single time
are opposed of me about our country one is the
political divide because a divide speaks of a
Chasm and a Chasm is an opportunity for someone
else to fill it and our adversaries are eager to
fill it with disinformation and other pernicious
acts number one and number two they ask about
guns yeah and then the number of killings in
our country and It is incomprehensible to them
it is and I want to move on to foreign
adversaries as well I just wanted to make
sure we we noted what's happening right now you
talked a little bit about threats to the Homeland
and specifically this 90-day threat assessment of
the risk posed by Beijing so exactly how embedded
are they at this point um in America's critical
infrastructure how vulnerable is it and when you
are looking at the threat assessment are you
looking in the scenario of planning for a war
well um I would say the following we have four
adverse nation states that are very focused on
targeting the United States the PRC Russia Iran
and North Korea they have since I last served
as a deputy secretary their capabilities have
only advanced in the realm of cyber security
they are focused on our on our critical
infrastructure they are focused on the
American public and disseminating disinformation
to misguide human behavior to the detriment
um uh the covid-19 pandemic and what its Origins
were uh the uh Russian unprovoked war against
Ukraine and what is the factual premise of that
uh our elections um are are our government leaders
and what they are about and what they're not about
it is widespread and pernicious the PRC is focused
on our intellectual property they produce Goods
that are manufactured by exploited labor and it
is our responsibility to ensure under the law
that no good produced by forced labor in holder
and part enters the United States we are we are
involved in every aspect of the threat that I
have just identified but are you planning for
the event of War here because some of what you
laid out including an attack on America's critical
infrastructure could be understood as exactly that
so um that's an incredibly aggressive action that
that is an incredibly uh aggressive action um and
I'm not sure I frame it in the context of War I
haven't applied that uh necessarily necessarily
A terminology but I don't think our actions uh
vary however one frames the issue we are focused
intensely on defending our critical infrastructure
through our cyber security and infrastructure
security agencies so I I think of it in terms of
an attack whether the attack is in the context of
war or day-to-day aggression I think our defenses
and our and our actions remain the same the FBI
director said that they opened a new investigation
into Chinese calendar intelligence every 10 hours
and half of their counter investigations are
related to China how significant right now is the
prc's exploitation of things like the Immigrant
system one of the things that we are very focused
on with respect to immigration in particular and
I referenced it in my remarks is what we call
non-traditional collection where individuals that
they will seek to abuse the student visa program
um other other lawful means of coming to the
United States individuals with intent uh to
collect information against us seek to exploit
our lawful Avenues but is there is there a metric
like that I mean how do you put a number on
how significant the threat is if there's a
counterintelligence investigation opened every 10
hours how significant would you I I have to tell
you um we considered extraordinarily significant
when we identify and prevent one individual
from seeking our sensitive information including
from our academic institutions that are doing
you know extraordinarily important work in
a public-private partnership the frequency
of the threat to which you refer Margaret I think
is a reflection of the magnitude of the threat the
um the keenness and focus of the prc's interest in
adversity and our incredible need for a tireless
vigilance the treasury secretary said yesterday
that the administration's considering restricting
U.S investment in sensitive Technologies with
significant National Security implications I know
you're concerned about Tick Tock but specifically
on this issue of Technology what concerns you
um where do you fit into that conversation within
the administration well we are a critical partner
of the committee on foreign investment in
the U.S the sypheus committee we are deeply
concerned about a PRC owned and operated
infrastructure elements of infrastructure
and what that control can mean given that the
operator and owner has adverse interests so
whether it's investment in in ports whether it is
investment in partner Nations telecommunications
channels and like it's a myriad of threats and I
have to say and allow me to emphasize that borders
physical borders are not necessarily
dispositive when it comes to the geography
of the threat and its potential impact on
the United States what do you mean by that
take cyberspace borders are irrelevant we can
have an end of it we have had an individual in
well maybe not this specifically but an individual
in pajamas uh at the age of 22 across the world in
the basement of the family home can do incredible
harm to the United States but at the end of this
90-day review are you going to be putting forward
recommendations on restrictions and new policies
rhetoric is changing and getting more aggressive
from the administration specifically on this so
I would say the following first of all allow me
to emphasize that the work is not beginning now
we've been doing this work uh since uh um many
years the review of tick tock has been going
on for years so that is a legal process so
that is a legal process before 2024 elections
I don't use the elections as a particular
threshold moment for addressing Homeland
Security threats but um let me say that um I
think that the focus and intensity of our work
encountering adverse nation states
is only intensifying and regrettably
their interests in doing us harm is only
intensifying so it's a correlative effort
um I want to ask you about the Border as
well um you said in testimony this week
that there is expected to be a surge that was
the you word you used of migrants after title
42 expires on May 11th um a CBP official put
that number at worst case between 11 and 13
000 people if no action is taken after May
11th so how do people think of what is about
to happen What planning are you putting in place
in these coming days so let me take a step back
in title 42 allows us which is a public health
authority not an immigration Authority in in
light of the covid-19 pandemic title 42 allows
us to expel an individual I mean essentially
turn them around turn them around without
permitting them to make a claim for Asylum
to turn them around very very quickly but it does
not create an immigration enforcement record it is
not formally a removal from the United States it's
an expulsion and what that means is that when one
is removed one has a five-year bar from admission
to the United States when one is expelled one can
try over and over again so when we speak of for
example 2.3 million Encounters in a single year
that is not 2.3 million Unique Individuals whom we
encounter that is 2.3 million encounters there's a
great deal of recidivism so while the expulsion is
very facilitating in terms of speed it is actually
not delivering a consequence so we have been
planning since September of 21 because we've
tried to end title 42 previously and been blocked
by the courts we've been planning since September
21 for the end of 42. we refreshed our six pillar
plan surging resources driving new efficiencies
um and using title eight are immigration
authorities expedited removal attacking the
cartels working with a non-profit organizations to
increase our reception capabilities working with
our International partners because it's critical
that they extend humanitarian relief under the
law their laws and that they enforce their borders
because we do have some countries that are Transit
countries where they because of the strain on
their system they facilitate the movement North
we've been doing all of that I think
we're going to be unveiling some new
efforts uh over the coming days our
our fundamental model is as follows
because one one has to understand that one
cannot deter one's way through a migration
challenge because it's relative one has
to understand the level of desperation
a parent feels when they are willing to send their
child in the hands of Smugglers to to Traverse a
country or multiple countries only to encounter
uh the challenge of the Southern border of the
United States so the level of desperation would
suggest that whatever deterrence we could impose
whether it's a facility or otherwise will not
work alone and so our model is as follows build
lawful pathways cut out the Smugglers who
exploit these vulnerable individuals build
lawful Pathways give individuals an opportunity
to reach the United States safely in an orderly
way to Avail themselves of the humanitarian relief
our laws provide and then deliver a consequence
for those who do not Avail themselves of those
lawful pathways it has worked extraordinarily well
um border crossings ticked up 25 from
February to March yes and I'll explain that
um on January 5th we implemented a program built
on that paradigm for Cubans Haitians nicaraguans
and Venezuelans we developed a parole program
up to 30 000 could come to the United States
per month and then we would deliver a consequence
for those who did not who arrived in our Southern
border we saw a 95 percent drop in the number
of individuals from those four nationalities at
our Southern border and you are moving into what
is traditionally migration season where movement
picks up typically so is that 13 000 number your
worst case scenario do you agree with CBP I no I
think what um well I don't disagree I think what
Troy Miller our acting commissioner was speaking
of is estimates that could materialize yeah
for which we have to be planning that is we
have to plan for different eventualities when
you speak of a 25 increase what we have seen
and there are reasons for this is an uptick in
the number of Venezuelans this month over last
but if you compare March of 2023 to March of 2022
you will still see a reduction so you are working
on a number of things still as I understand it
in terms of uh the understanding with Mexico
you also have to make a decision according to the
Washington post about whether to detain families
no decision has been made when will that decision
be made I know you ended the practice in 2021 how
important is it I know you said deterrence isn't
enough but how you explain this matters so uh
let me just make clear that deterrence alone
will not solve the challenge of migration with
respect to the United States with respect to
any country in the world that is experiencing
it and I have to tell you it is gripping
the entire hemisphere Colombia is host to
2.5 million Venezuelans Venezuela has seen the
immigration of about eight percent 20 percent of
its population I think it is a population of 28
30 million people more than 8 million have left
so this is gripping the hemisphere we're going
to be making decisions in the coming days
is that your decision I imagine it's sitting
with the president still being weighed
um so I'm I won't talk about
the deliberative process
um but we we as a government are responsible for
the decisions that we make we work as one team
um there are estimates that 600 000 migrants
evaded agents last year and entered the U.S
illegally so when you're talking about use of
technology and looking at that you're already
using drones what kind of Technology helps reduce
those who do slip through the net of the border
patrol agents so we use towers that provide just
their Force multiplier in terms of the visibility
that they give agents to Canvas a significant
swath of land let me share something about the six
hundred thousand godaways that's how it's that's
how it's termed what is the metric of success
when one speaks of or of progress or status when
one speaks of the security of the Border I would
think that a reasonable metric would be what
percentage of the people who attempt to cross
the border are we apprehending if one takes the
number of apprehensions uh one takes the number
of godaways adds those together what percentage of
that aggregate as the denominator is the numerator
of apprehensions but you are looking to reduce
the godaways oh absolutely that's and everything's
answer to that and well if you take a look at
our apprehension rate in 2023 it was higher
uh than I believe two years in the prior
Administration and we have been pretty consistent
in our apprehension rate over the past seven eight
years our apprehension rate is close to 80 percent
it was lower uh I don't recall whether it's 2019
2020 I think it was 71 74 but it's basically in
one year in the prior Administration it
was higher it was in the 80s it's been
pretty consistent and to me that is the that
is a reasonable metric of evaluating how our
enforcement efforts are working our rate
of apprehension we have surged more border
patrol agents than other officers to the Border
we are using more technology than ever before we
are maximizing the resources that we have to to
achieve the most effective results it is our hope
that we are funded at the level we need to be
the talk of taking our budget and reducing it
to a prior level will will harm our our border
security efforts our efforts to battle the PRC
our efforts to battle online child sexual
exploitation everything about which I spoke
um when you Justified to Congress last month
you said you were looking at AI as a potential
Force multiplier for border patrol agents I
imagine to address all of these issues so do
you have a metric yet of the success rate or are
these just tabletop exercises at this point when
you're speaking of AI yes oh I think we're
at a nascent stage of really deploying uh AI
um uh I I think we're now at the dawn of a new
age not a phrase I coined by the way uh Dimitri
Dimitri kutsanov here our under secretary
for the office of Science and Technology
Eric heisen who is wearing two hats as our Chief
Information officer they are going to be leading
um our our task force on the use of AI
you said it was to deal with mundane tasks
oh I I let the border patrol agents aren't
tied up with it but that's one that's one
use and a very pivotal use but I think that
we the task force cannot be restricted to
I wouldn't use the mundane I would use the daily
critical work I think we just have to open widen
that aperture speak with other experts in this
room and elsewhere about what how what is the how
and how does one Define the aperture we shouldn't
do it unilaterally we have to reimagine but when
you look at who essentially the adversary is when
you're talking about cartels who are trafficking
humans yes how because I know when when you've
been on my program in the past you've talked
about how sophisticated the technology
has gotten in terms of evading agents yes
um where are where are the cartels in terms of
that level of sophistication and us matching it
you know I'm thinking of that when you were
on with me and 53 migrants had just died in
the back of a tractor-trailer in San Antonio and
they got through the Border without being detected
so Margaret two two thoughts one that speaks to
the depravity of the traffickers they they don't
care about people's lives and two it speaks
to the criticality of the 305 million dollars
funding that we are seeking in fiscal year
2024 to purchase more non-intrusive inspection
technology so that we can actually get
to the point of screening 100 percent
of the trailers the the trucks the passenger
vehicles that come through our border we are
not at a hundred percent we have increased our
volume materially over the past several years
but we are not at a hundred percent that's why
continued investment is so critical I want to make
sure that we get to some of the questions from our
members who are invited right now to ask them this
is on the record we started a little late so if
you're watching the clock I'm making up the time
um so here do you want to start here I think
there are microphones to be run around this
gentleman here in the third row yes to what extent
is the citizenship Clause of the 14th Amendment a
lure for people across the border illegally and
if so is there anything that can be done about
it like a a reinterpretation so that at least one
parent must be a citizen or lawful resident alien
so um the citizenship Clause meaning uh what
do you mean the the fact that the birthright
citizenship um I don't you know this is um my
immediate reaction to the question is I don't
think that a parent who cannot send his or
her daughter to school safely in the morning
or is concerned about their son ability to live
to live if they choose not to join a gang is
thinking of actually coming to the United States
for the purpose of having another child
so that child could become a U.S citizen
front row Jane Harmon desperation desperation is
the greatest catalyst for the migration that we
are seeing on 9 11 I was serving in Congress I
co-chaired co-chaired in this was a republican
majority Congress a subcommittee on terrorism of
the intelligence committee with Saxby chamblers
who went on to become a senator the rhetoric
around 9 11 was America is under attack
on the night of 9 11 150 Plus members of Congress
assembled on the steps of the Capitol which had
just been reopened and sang God Bless America
no one was talking about gee it's the Democrats
fault it's the Republicans fault and when we
enacted legislation following 9 11 including
standing up your department uh the uh creating
the Director of National Intelligence and a
variety of other things the votes were
bipartisan 22 years later forget about
it and the demonizing of you personally is to
me shocking and totally unproductive but my
question is thought experiment imagine if Chuck
Schumer and Kevin McCarthy came to visit you
imagine thought experiment and asked
you what are a few things that Congress
could do productively in addition to
adding some funding that you mentioned
productively to make our homeland effort
more effective what would those few things be
um so the first thing that comes to mind Jane
is the fact that they already had done something
which is they had come together uh to speak with
the Secretary of Homeland Security about what
could be done for the well-being of our homeland
so that would be a mission one accomplished
um immigration reform uh the the system is
so broken everyone agrees about it and yet
we can't uh seem uh to come together to fix
it um uh reauthorizing our counter uas our
counter-drone authorities the use of drones
they're they're their speed their capacity
for payloads the distance they can travel their
sophistication in terms of their visibility we
have got to have that Authority reauthorized we
should authorize our cyber safety review board
an extraordinary development over the last year it
should be codified are countering weapons of mass
destruction uh office needs to be reauthorized uh
we we need to be funded to protect the Homeland
you know every single year since 2006 we have
relied on the National Guard to supplement our
Personnel at the border every single year we
need to be self-sustaining we need to take a
look we need to take a look at the Department of
Homeland Security's imperatives and not view it
through the lens of politics but view it through
the lens of security we all came together as a
country after 9 11. we failed to come together as
a country after individuals broke into our capital
and were screaming um words of killing
both the speaker and our vice president
Republican leadership has said they're supportive
of the idea of dealing with the border which seems
to be separated from immigration that you just
talked about so are you more optimistic that you
will get something on that narrower framing I am
an unrelenting Optimist but I will share with you
the following that what uh was articulated this
week is that we cannot fit you know we cannot fix
our immigration system the fact that we have 10
to 11 million vacant jobs we have an incredible
um supply of labor and we're not marrying the
two we will not fix something like that until
you secure the border and my view of that
is it is a remarkable formula that one is
holding the the solution hostage until
one fixes the problem that's just an
interesting mathematical equation to me okay
can we have here in the second row and then
he has her hand up I think in that last row
thank you Alan Raul from the Law Firm sidley
Austin secretary mayorka said going back to
artificial intelligence in your remarks you
talked about the tremendous promise that that
artificial intelligence offers for the key
missions of the department including
cyber security and others you talked
about the need for transparency
and explain a bit explainability
um there are some challenges to artificial
intelligence as well explainability of secretary
Mr Kissinger and Eric Schmidt wrote In The Wall
Street Journal a fabulous piece about perhaps lack
of explainability some of the technologists have
done uh said that as well that they don't really
know how the magic Works Elon Musk and others have
written a letter about the apparel to civilization
that they see in artificial intelligence along
with its tremendous promise will your task force
with your department in addition to looking how
to deploy artificial intelligence to help make
country more secure look at some of these
metaphysical issues along with the mundane
about the the challenges of understanding and
what it really means for civilization is that a
homeland security issue that your department your
task force will also consider so I I think given
um our to-do list um I will say that the
economist has a um its latest edition
addresses uh AI quite extensively I haven't yet
cracked it but given our to-do list I think I'm
going to leave the metaphysics to somebody
else I think we're going to be operational
in that back row please hello secretary my name
is Alejandra I'm a reporter for FS Spanish news
agency so you mentioned in regards to immigration
after a May 11 you mentioned the Terence and
you also mentioned there's going to be more
consequences for people who cross between ports
of Entry but you also mentioned desperation that
that's the greatest Catalyst for migration don't
you think these two three things spread together
are going to be putting migrants at bigger risks
that people who want to come to the US are
going to be drive towards more risky situations
especially given what happened in Mexico with the
fire that killed more than Terry people in Juarez
and the second thing is um Bob Menendez proposed
using the parole to be able to solve what you
also mentioned that is great need for labor in
the country and be using that for more people
coming in more migration what do you say to that
thank you so much thank you so much I spoke to one
of your colleagues from fa in in Panama just just
last week as we negotiated a trilateral agreement
with Panama and Colombia to address the security
of the border between those two countries and the
fact that too many people are risking their lives
and frankly losing their lives or suffering trauma
even should they survive when they enter the
Darien I think it is a humanitarian obligation
to prevent individuals from taking that journey
in the hands of Smugglers so I do not think that
our approach actually drives a greater risk
it is when I speak of lawful Pathways and a
consequence for those who do not Avail themselves
there's a predicate to that and the predicate is
that the lawful pathways are meaningful they're
accessible they're real as they have been in the
parole program that we announced and implemented
on the 5th of January um uh the parole program the
the discretionary Authority that I have is based
on two independent foundations one is an urgent
humanitarian reason and the other is a significant
public benefit we've exercised that Authority
prudently and effectively the parole program for
Cubans Haitians nicaraguans and Venezuelans is
working the clamor that we hear to reduce the
number of encounters at our Southern border
we met we met that objective through the with
respect to those forward populations through
our programs and nevertheless our Parole
Authority with respect to those successful
programs is being challenged in a court in Texas
so our Parole Authority and it's its ability
to serve the public benefit to address urgent
humanitarian needs is actually being challenged
um can we have this gentleman here with the Violet
shirt and then the young lady in the back on this
side of the room thank you Mr secretary it's Jim
freeze I wanted to ask you about something you've
not talked about and that's Financial intelligence
and particularly looking back when you were at CIS
when I was at treasury fincen we had built upon
capacity building with Mexico but it was always
an issue in terms of corruption whether we could
trust them but we finally were able to have a
breakthrough in looking at the way money moves
you talked about immigration but of course we
know that uh whether it's narcotics whether it's
guns moving across the border whether it's trade
based money laundering money is always another
side of those flows and I fear that some of the
aspects we were able to actually have the Mexican
government change ways the use of the dollar to
distinguish between illicit flows and legal flows
that we wanted to let flourish I fear that that
went away in the last Administration but can you
talk a little bit about that aspect of partnership
and how integral you view that for DHS today um
so you know the the the maximum follow the money
uh uh is critical you know when I first started
as a prosecutor in 1989 my first series of cases
were actually on asset forfeiture um the um the
instruments the property the finances that were
used to fund or facilitate the underlying illegal
activity or the companion legal activity or the
proceeds of that illegal activity I have to tell
you I addressed some defendants who didn't seem
to Blink an eye with doing a few years in custody
but when one took all their money away it was a
huge huge deal we are so focused on this and by
the way that landscape speaking of an evolution
in the threat landscape cryptocurrency has
you know revolutionized our work in that
regard we are intensely focused uh on the on
the financial aspects of criminal and adverse
behavior and one of the greatest advances I
think that has occurred within the Department
of Homeland Security is the maturation of
Homeland Security investigations within
Immigration and Customs Enforcement as a really
Premier law investigative law enforcement agency
so we are very focused on that not just
domestically with respect to property
and and you know proceeds facilitation of
criminal activity here and with an in with
the connectivity uh across the border or uh abroad
uh but we are working with our partner Nations uh
very extensively Rob Silvers is here our under
secretary for strategy policy and plans leading
our International efforts this is uppermost
in our mind and we have an a great partnership
with Mexico in that regard and we have our
transnational criminal investigative units tcius
to work in Partnership to address not
just the movement of the Controlled
Substances or the people but also the
instrumentalities of their criminality
we are running out of time here so if
you could keep your question very quick
and we will conclude um hi I'm Rebecca with the
hill I wanted to ask you about your appearances
before Congress this week on a more personal
level Republicans are increasingly commenting
on your personal character during these
hearings I was curious how you feel about
those comments and what's going through your
mind during some of these exchanges foreign
[Laughter]
you know they are not easy um to um listen to
um they also have ramifications
that I wish individuals in positions
of leadership would consider
um because um
our work is about people and it's about the people
doing the work the people affected by the work
about our institutions our norms our definition
as a country of values and principles
I am fundamentally fundamentally though I'm
impervious to them because I may make some
mistakes but I you know my decisions uh May from
uh may be mistaken some may disagree with them
but I have a hundred percent confidence
in the Integrity of my decision making
so thank you I think that's a good
note to end on thank you secretary
mayorkas and please note that the video
and the transcript of today's meeting will
be posted on the council's website thank
you all thank you Margaret thank you all